Hello, everybody.
I forgot I was muted.
Hello, hello.
Thank you for the five.
Give the shit smack.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I know, like, I don't sound tired, right?
It's like I was awake for a while.
Yes.
There's someone, somebody is getting stronger and smarter every day.
So, um, I've been awake since eight in the morning.
Um, I've only had five hours of sleep because somebody!
Somebody!
Oh, oh, oh, there he is, sleeping beside me.
Someone was like, feed me!
Feed me!
And then, like, and then after I fed him, he was like, that's right.
Now, walk me!
Walk me!
Alright, so, uh, dad update.
He is, I don't know how every day is a new dad update, but he, somehow, every day is a new dad update.
So, um, lately, he has become smarter and smarter every day.
He's adapting.
He's evolving.
Um, because, uh, what he's learned, when I realized he, like, barks a little too much early in the morning when I'm very fucking tired, he, like, I would, like, I have this, like, bark collar next to me.
Like, it's, by the way, some people were, I, there was a short related to it, and they're like, oh, man, um, I can't believe, like, oh, why were you using a bark collar?
But, like, the thing is, I've only used it for, like, like, maybe, like, three days in his entire life.
And that's when he was, like, younger.
Like, you know, when he was, like, one or two years old.
So, like, but the trauma stays with him for years.
So, like, because, like, he knows.
He knows what it does.
Like, I've only used it, like, two or three days when he was, like, one, one years older, one or two years old.
But, like, he's still... it's been years and he still remembers.
The trauma still stays with him.
Because it's, like, the only way for him to, like, learn.
Because it's, like, smaller dogs are actually a lot harder to train when it comes to, like, barking.
Especially wiener dogs.
Wiener dogs just love to be loud.
So it's, like, a struggle.
If you've ever owned a wiener dog, you know how loud they can be.
And, like, they have, like, the second loudest bark out of all the dog breeds.
Wiener dogs, dachshunds, have the second loudest barks out of all dog breeds.
Which is fucking crazy.
Because of how tiny they are.
So, they're so fucking tiny.
But they're so loud.
So, I've used this bark collar for three days.
No, they are.
They are much louder than corkies.
Like, it's crazy.
But, like, the trauma stays with him.
So, you know.
So, I keep his bark collar next to me in bed the last couple of days.
Because, like, um...
Because the dog sitter was feeding him early.
So, like, he's been waking me up at 7 to 8 a.m.
because of it.
Because, like, that's his new routine now.
Um...
So...
So, that's why I've had his bark collar beside my bed whenever he does that.
And all I have to do is show him when he comes into my room.
And goes, like...
Walk me!
Feed me!
I just...
Still in my bed.
In my pillow.
Just find the bark collar.
Don't even look up.
And just show it to him.
And then he, like...
Oh, shit.
And then he walks away.
And then goes back to bed.
And he's like...
Okay, I can...
You know what?
I can wait an hour.
I can wait an extra hour.
That's alright.
You know?
Nah, it's okay.
I'll just wait an extra hour.
And...
And then I get to sleep.
Maybe an additional hour or two.
Anyway.
He's learned.
He has evolved and adapted today.
Um...
After he realized that, like...
I couldn't do this forever.
Because you know what he started doing?
He...
Because I was like, What the fuck is going on?
Because...
Okay, it was so weird.
So after I fed him...
Because I was like...
Oh my god.
Okay, I'll just feed you.
And I'll satisfy you for at least like two hours.
Before you wake me up to walk.
So...
I fed him at like...
Eight in the morning.
And then I went back to bed.
And then...
For some reason...
I heard distant barking.
And I was so confused.
I was like...
It's a little far away.
What is he barking at?
And then I was like...
Why is it like...
So far away?
It's not in my room.
It's not in my bedroom.
It's not like...
In the living room.
It's like a little far.
And I got very confused.
And then he kept going at it.
I was like, what the fuck is going on?
So, you know, obviously, I got concerned.
Because I was like, that's new!
And I got up, and I looked and I was like, where the fuck is he?
I couldn't- I didn't know where he was.
I was like, he's not at the front door.
Because, you know, my first thought was like, I swear to fucking God, if he, like, is waiting for me at the front door to demand to be walked, I swear to God.
But I walked to the front door and he wasn't there.
So I got confused.
I was like looking at the room in the living room.
I was looking at his bed in the living room.
I was like, and I was like, did he lock himself in the bathroom?
Like, is that it?
Because the bathroom door was just slightly open and he didn't know how to get out.
I was like, no, he's not there.
And this little fucker, this little fucker, um, was in my office underneath my table.
And he was like, barking from underneath my table in my office.
And he was like, that's right.
You can't get me now.
And I was like, what are you doing?
I was like, come on, come over here.
And he was like, no, I'm gonna be under this table.
That's right.
You can't get me.
Try to bring that back on it.
I'm right here where you work.
Don't test me.
That's right.
Oh, what if I fuck up your PC where you work?
I was like, I was like, what the fuck are you?
Come on, get out of here.
It's like, no, I'm not getting out until you walk me.
And then so...
So anyway, anyway, so I was like, I went back to my bed.
I was like, fuck you.
I'm just gonna go back to my bed.
Like, you can't stay there forever.
But he can.
It's like...
He can.
Because the moment I went back to the bed, he started barking again underneath my desk in my office.
And he's like, that's what you're gonna do.
You're gonna try and bring the bark on it.
That's right.
You have no power here.
And I was just like, what the...
Because he's never done that before.
He's never, like, threaded me like this before.
And so...
So I was like, oh, fuck.
Okay.
Alright.
Like, obviously, I'm more awake now.
Because he made me get out from my bed to, like, try and find him.
So, like, obviously, I'm more awake as well.
Because, like, I don't know if that was also his plan.
He's like, that's right.
Move!
Now that you're up, you might as well walk me.
And now that you're not in bed, you might as well walk me.
Because I was like...
I was like, fuck, okay.
Now I'm not as tired.
Because, like, I had to get up and find this fucker.
Seja, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
I always enjoy watching your streams.
So, like, at point, I was like, fuck.
And then the moment I got up and put on my jacket, he ran to the front door.
Because he knew.
The moment he hears me put on the jacket, he's like, I won.
And he ran to the front door.
He didn't wait for me to go to the front door.
He heard jacket sounds.
And he's like, that's right.
I won.
This little fucker.
I was like, oh my god, he's so lucky.
I was just too tired to fight back at that point.
I know people were like, you should really not let him do this to you or take advantage of you.
I'm so tired, guys.
You don't understand.
I was weak.
He got me when I was at my weakest, guys.
I was weak today.
I couldn't try and outstubborn him.
I couldn't outstubborn him.
I was way too tired and he knew I was weak today.
And like, he won this morning.
He won.
I had to order myself another fucking cup of coffee.
This one was another special shots.
I'm gonna try not drink coffee later for at least a week after this because I drank a lot of caffeine for the last couple of days.
I drank a lot of caffeine the last couple of days.
So I'm just trying not to drink caffeine the next week or two just so I don't depend on it.
I was... I'm just so fucking tired right now.
I've been like so busy too.
I've been incredibly busy like this week and last... this week and last week too.
So like I had to have caffeine.
I'm literally like caffeinated up right now.
Anyway.
So... so he won this morning.
Like... and like he has a new strategy against me.
Um... and alright.
So not the end of dad updates because... um... oh my god.
He's such a whore.
Doki Amber Doge is such a fucking whore.
Um... so like you'll be like, oh what happened?
Okay.
Well, obviously...
It's pretty lady time.
Alright.
So obviously I was taking him to the dog part, right?
He... there was a pretty lady and he like went straight towards her.
And I was like, yep, of course.
Alright.
Um... pretty lady time.
Okay.
And then... oh my god.
So... so... he like walked up to the pretty lady.
Pretty lady bent down.
And then... she was like, aww, and like starts... like you know, pet him a little bit.
And she's like... you know, pa?
Pa!
And this fucker was like, oh, you want me to give you pot?
You know what else I can give you?
That's even better.
And then he rolls on to like his back like, that's right.
This is better than a pot.
She was just like, okay, pot.
And he instantly like, yeah, you want a pot?
No, no, no.
No, touch me on my belly.
That's how like I see it.
And you make it sound so creepy.
Because I was like, why the fuck did you?
Like, she was just trying to be like, pot.
And then he instantly was like, no, no, no.
I want you to rub my belly.
He's such a creep.
That's what I'm saying.
I was like, he's such a whore.
He's...
Before.
He's done a...
The last time I saw him like roll on his back.
Where someone at the dog park was for that white dog.
The...
What was the giant white...
Not an Eskimo dog.
I forgot what they were called.
The really fluffy ones.
Now, remember the one where I showed you guys a picture?
Where he like rolled around.
I was like, yes, lick my ear.
Like that part?
Yeah, the ear licker.
Yeah, the Samoyed.
That was the last time he like rolled on his back.
Was for that Samoyed for like ear licking.
So now he did it again.
But this time for a pretty lady.
And I'm just like, oh my god.
I was like...
I was so...
I don't know.
I was a little...
Disappointed.
Because I was like...
Don't show your belly right away.
Don't ask for random strangers who are fucking belly rubs.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Why are you getting freakier?
Why are you so freaky?
No belly on the first day.
Not even a hello?
All she wanted was a paw.
But free of belly rubs though.
The confidence is off the chart.
But yeah.
Anyway, that was some dad update for today.
Golden Helm.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dad software updates are getting out of hand.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Pets resemble their owner.
So I wonder what this says about...
That's not true!
I did not teach him that.
I...
Oh, he left.
I didn't even realize he left a while ago.
He's like, oh man.
You're gonna talk shit about me?
Fuck you.
I'm leaving this room.
He was sleeping next to me.
And then I was like, dad update.
And then he like disappeared.
I didn't even realize he disappeared until now.
I...
He didn't like the slander.
Usually like...
I've never seen him roll on his back for a pretty lady before.
So this is like the first time I was...
Oh my god.
Fucking whore.
But clearly, he's like, you're not enough for me.
Why don't you rub my belly like these ladies?
You used to rub my belly all the time.
I'm...
Anyway.
But yes, that is all of that update for today.
Today we're also gonna...
Today we're also gonna be finishing Super Mario Man.
We're at the final area.
I believe it's basically like the Elite Four.
The Elite Four in Pokemon.
So yeah.
I'm kind of happy to finish another game this week.
I might have overscheduled.
My week, despite how busy I am.
Oh my god.
I've been like...
Basically, I've been like doing a million things behind the scenes at this point.
Because of so many things that are coming up.
There's like, you know, the AX concert and everything.
But there's like other stuff as well behind the scenes.
So like...
I made a little mistake overscheduling my week today.
Like not...
Sorry.
Overscheduling my week.
But I also really, really, really wanted to finish Super Mario Mod.
Because we've been playing that game for a while now.
And...
I just...
Really...
Wait, what is this?
Uh...
Oh, okay.
Never...
Sorry.
I got a Discord message.
I was like...
What is this message about?
Sorry.
I had to...
I was just like being like...
Wait, who's this person again?
Anyway.
But I really want to finish Super Mario Mod because it has been a while.
And I personally don't like having a super duper long game series.
Just because like...
Just because I feel like...
You know, sometimes it does tend to drag on a while.
Especially if it's like...
Prolong to a long...
Like...
Prolong for like...
You know...
Like more than one month.
So I do want to like...
Try and wrap things up and stuff.
So I can play newer games.
And...
Like experience like new games.
New playthroughs.
And other stuff.
And also...
You know, I want to finish Onimusha.
Because you know...
There was just one more part.
And then we'll be done.
And...
No, it wasn't Frail.
She's baiting you.
And...
Sorry, I got like...
Oh my god.
Why are you like...
I have so many discs right now.
Like a...
Excuse me.
I am stream...
Oh yeah.
They don't know that I'm streaming.
I always appear offline.
So no one knows whenever I'm online or offline.
So people won't...
I don't...
I don't know.
This is a me thing.
But...
I always appear offline on...
I'm always offline on Discord.
Appear offline on Discord.
Because I don't like when people know whenever I am online.
And then...
Because like usually when people...
I found out...
This was like something I learned.
Learned...
When I learned in my past.
Was that...
Whenever I like appear online.
I get like a lot more messages.
And like a lot of people like...
Poking me for things.
But if I always am up here offline.
People...
No one will know whenever I'm actually on.
To like...
Ask me for things.
Because so like...
No one will know.
So they'll just like...
You know...
Send the message whenever they can.
Because they'll never know whenever I'm online.
But yeah.
So that...
You know...
I could just...
If I have like a little small break.
I could...
They have to guess when I'll be active.
Exactly.
They'll have to guess.
Now everyone will know.
No.
Everyone knows.
I like...
People who I actually like...
Work with.
Or like...
Talk to.
They know I'm always up here offline.
Because I haven't been like...
Online.
On Discord.
For like...
Three plus years now.
JL.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Because I've learned.
In the past...
I would have like...
I would also like...
Like before I started doing that...
Hide my game status.
Or like whatever I'm on.
So people won't know.
Like you know...
If I'm like...
Playing a game.
Or like doing something...
On like an app.
Or something.
People will like...
Poke me.
And be like...
You know like...
When I used to play Apex.
Or Overwatch.
People see me on Overwatch.
Or Apex.
And they'll be like...
Oh do you want to play...
Do you want to play Apex?
Or like...
Oh why are you playing Apex?
You should be doing that.
And then like...
At that point I learned how to like...
Not show my game status.
But then I found out...
It was easier to just never...
Be online.
Like...
I just...
Just never be online.
And then no one will know.
No one...
Will know if I'm busy or not.
Yeah anyway.
Anyway.
It's Super Mario Man time.
Let me...
Boot up that game real quick.
I'm excited.
I don't even know how much I actually technically have left.
I know we're just at the Leaf board.
But like...
Where's my controller though?
Wait.
Where did I put my controller?
Okay.
That's...
Last time I'll hear this song.
Oh yeah.
Also like...
I have to be like...
Less greedy about...
Oh wait.
I need to reboot.
Never mind.
I have to be like...
Not greedy.
Less selfish about the games I want to play.
After this week.
It's time to play.
It's time to return the flavor of the month.
And streamer games.
I may or may not have been incredibly...
Not incredibly.
I may or may not have been like indulging...
Indulging...
In things that...
In like...
The most like...
Obscure type of games.
That people...
Might not know...
Where it came from.
So welcome back to...
Friend's lab.
Where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Oh.
Oh okay.
I was like...
Okay, okay.
As long as you're having fun.
Yeah, we play a lot of...
Very, very niche games lately.
So I...
But next week...
Next week...
We'll be back to Elden Ring.
So at least...
You know...
At least we have one...
Popular streamer game.
Alright.
I think the...
The only issue...
The main issue is that...
I like indulging in these like...
Niche...
Being selfish...
A little selfish...
And playing these like...
Uh...
Very niche...
And...
Uh...
Obscure games...
Like...
Uh...
But the thing is...
Oh, I peer into the abyss below.
The thing is...
Some of these games...
Take a really, really long time...
And sees a castle of lava...
Jump into the hole...
Alright, here we go...
Yeah, that's my issue...
At the moment...
I get a little selfish with that...
Okay, Kamek...
Gah, Mario...
Wait, I'm supposed to be here...
Calm down...
Hmm...
I...
The Honorable Kamek...
I'm here in Lord Bowser's place...
He was officially invited by Princess...
To be part of this so-called...
Elite Four...
But he's being somewhat of a...
Sword loser...
I mean...
He's not feeling well...
And so...
That is why...
Aw...
Lord Bowser...
Uh...
Aw...
Lord Bowser's going through a heartbreak right now...
JL, thank you for the super chat...
Thank you, thank you...
RepoTap...
Gambit, thank you for the super chat...
Thank you, thank you...
I blame you for that, Burb...
Gambit, thank you for the super chat...
Thank you, thank you...
Hmm...
And so...
That is why I am here...
Me and my masterful stratagem...
Shall finally defeat you, Mario!
But that's not to say...
I won't like playing more niche games...
I just gotta be a...
Less...
A little less selfish and actually follow the algorithm just a little bit.
And then I can be selfish again, chat.
Don't worry.
I may or may not have been not following the algorithm.
Just doing whatever.
Mr. Broken Bond.
Thank you, Mr. Super Chat.
Thank you.
I know a great short game to play.
It's got Expedition 33.
Probably should be able to finish in just one day.
Yeah, we need a balance between niche and numbers.
Alright.
Oh.
Oh, he's sending himself.
He wants to get beat up already?
Okay.
Not gonna lie.
I feel like...
I feel like if...
If you send in yourself and I fucking beat the shit out of you that you faint, you should not be allowed to keep going after that.
I don't know.
I just feel like he should, like, stop.
I think he...
Like, the battle should just end, like, at that point.
Um...
Uh, bu-bu-bu-but.
I donate.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
That's his son.
Kamek Jr. I mean, okay.
Then take him to the hospital.
I literally beat up your fucking son.
Sleepy Miracle.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Follow the algorithm.
Don't break the matrix.
Alright.
Storm throw.
Get over here.
Okay.
What?
Oh, wait.
I forgot.
Like, I was like, what the fuck?
You're all fire.
I'm fire too.
That's like, how are you doing so much?
We're both the same people.
How are you doing so much?
You and me are the same.
Okay.
Thank God.
Golden Shroom.
Wait.
Actually?
Yeah.
Golden Shroom.
Don't worry, Dad.
Eat.
Keep eating.
Be big and sh...
We're not doing...
It's not time yet.
It's not time.
Oh, I had some mushrooms.
Oh, I think I do.
I already forgot, like, exactly what I have.
Nice.
Goodbye, Blarg.
Yeah.
What's most squirrel?
Oh, that's the octopus one, right?
I'm pretty sure.
He'll be fine.
That's the octopus guy.
Yeah, I knew it.
It's the fire water.
Alright.
Chuck him.
Yes.
Scald.
Okay, that's just...
Wait, that's water.
Wait.
No, wait.
No.
I was like, that's fine.
I was like, oh, wait.
That's water.
Fire.
Why?
Dragon.
It's okay.
We're fine.
Everything will be fine.
What even is Breakdown Mullen?
Does egg bomb work?
Okay, that's good.
Okay.
Don't worry.
He also bombed me.
But it's okay.
Alright.
You're just...
Don't worry.
You're just a little bit poisoned.
It's okay.
It's just food poisoning.
It's so...
It's just...
Oh, it ignores your ability.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Also, let me know if the game music is a little too loud.
Because I...
So, apparently...
Apparently, during the final level...
The final stage...
The...
The game music gets a little bit too loud.
Let me know.
Yeah!
It's okay.
You're just only a little hurt.
Don't worry.
Okay.
Red Yoshi.
It's kind of a little loud.
Okay.
I'll turn it down a little bit.
Alright.
Bomb.
That's egg bomb.
That's alright.
It's Yoshi versus Yoshi.
Oh my god.
He also egg bombed.
Oh wait.
Nice.
69.
Okay.
You both missed.
It's like...
The battle of the egg bomb.
Alright.
It's literally...
Whoever egg bombs first.
Alright.
Nice.
You did...
Okay.
Goodbye.
I forgot.
I forgot like...
They stopped one more.
Alright.
Should be fine.
It's okay.
You died for the cause.
You died for...
You died for our sins.
Okay.
Oh, it's the angry son.
I hope I was at least a tough imponent.
Uh...
Oh yeah.
High horsepower first.
Because it's the first move.
What are you gonna do?
Cut me with the sun?
Oh, that's what you're gonna do.
Oh.
What the hell?
Whoa.
Wait.
That's a little...
Oh, that's okay.
That's okay.
Real sun.
You did it.
I knew you could do it.
I knew I could always count on you.
Solar Blade is a grass move?
It has fire and blade in it.
How can it be grass?
What?
Are you expecting to yell out to Lord Bowser for forgiveness?
I'll have you know.
I'd actually rather enjoy this game the princess put on.
This was my one chance to show off my strategies to your full potential.
So I'm just a little depressed.
Put me wallowing in peace already.
Wait.
Is he at the Elite Four?
He's at the Elite Four, right?
Okay.
Yeah, he is.
Oh.
I forgot.
This is the Elite Four.
There's no Pokemon Center.
Oh, wait.
I should not...
I should not have let Dad die.
Oh.
I was like, don't worry.
I can just heal up at this.
Guys, it's been so long since I...
It's so...
It's pretty noticeable that I haven't played Pokemon in a long fucking time.
I actually forgot that.
You don't...
You can't just go get healed per fight.
You have to heal...
Use your items.
Oh.
Guys, this is so long.
I gave up on Pokemon.
After it was at Pokemon X and Y.
If you guys didn't remember, Pokemon X and Y was 10 plus years ago, chat.
Salutations, Mario.
Surprised to see you here?
I'll have you know, I'm not just some old researcher.
I helped design the entire Cap Challenge alongside the Princess.
Which means I know more than anyone about how to battle.
Let me show you.
Stop.
I don't need to hear this.
Wait, we did this.
That's when gold and silver came up.
Right, guys?
Right?
Oh, yeah.
It's not...
Yeah, 12...
Sorry.
I meant 12 years ago.
Alright, let's...
Let's crush him.
That's right.
Get crushed.
Oh, fuck.
No, not...
Dude, does everybody know ground moves?
Like, what's...
What's the point of being Elite Four if you all are in the same move sense?
Why do you all know Earthquake?
Why do you all know ground moves?
You might as well just be the Elite Ground.
Oh, King Boo?
That's right.
Oh, the battle of the century.
Which king shall reign supreme?
Because it's good.
That's right.
A ghost weighs nothing.
The king...
Please stop making all the 38-year-old draggoods in chat sad.
Including me.
But...
That's okay.
Oh, look!
There's Rice Goon.
Is this, like, as easy to kill?
Yep.
Just as easy to kill as my Mario mod.
My high pause seems to be true.
You truly are all skilled.
Wait, why am I confused?
Dad, why are you conf...
Okay, it doesn't matter.
You can still heatcrash.
Yay!
Goodbye.
Okay, the hardest one was actually the first one.
Because he fucking knows Earthquake.
Goodbye!
Incredible.
You truly outdone yourself, Mario.
Yay!
I did it.
Wonderfully done, Mario.
You made an old scientist weep with joy.
To think.
You put so much time and effort into the game I came up with.
It moves me to tears.
Go on.
Do me proud and finish your cap challenge.
Alright.
Oh yeah, shit.
Oh wait.
I need to go this way.
Work back.
I was like, where the fuck?
Where's the door?
I was like, where the fuck is the door?
Alright, let me check the pee pee moves.
Real quick.
I need to check if dad has enough.
Okay.
Just to be safe.
Let me...
Let's see.
I should have an extra...
Syrup.
Like a small syrup.
Because I don't want to use...
Do I?
Okay.
I don't want to use the one that heals all of them.
Alright.
We just need heat crash.
What's this one?
I see Peach's castle.
Jump into the hole?
Okay.
Let's see.
I know I'm fighting Luigi last.
So...
I'll beat up...
My...
Uh...
Sorry.
I'll...
Let me rephrase that.
Let me think of how I rephrase it so it doesn't sound that bad.
Uh...
Yeah?
What?
I'll...
Do a...
Non-violent...
Mario...
Battle...
That's for fun...
Against my girlfriend.
Oh, grassy brains.
Let's go.
That should be easy.
And it's all fun and games.
And everybody is in on it.
Yippee!
And there's cameras everywhere.
Master Mario!
You've done well to make it this far.
The princess has given me the great honor.
Of being in charge of this arena.
What type will I use?
Well...
I'll have you know.
I...
Used to work a lot with dragons back in my day.
Now then...
Let us do battle!
Oh my god.
He fucking invaded me.
I...
I thought...
It said grassy planes.
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
He's a dragon trainer.
Like...
What the fuck?
It said grassy planes.
And I was like...
Brassy planes.
Aw man.
I have the perfect mind for this fight.
Oh no!
Grass!
Oh shit.
I forgot this guy.
Fire doesn't do well against him.
Oh you're gonna just withdraw him?
Just cause he like is flattened?
Oh my god.
Is this...
It's him.
It's you.
Alright.
It's fine.
It's so...
It's vormon.
Nice.
Yeah!
Oh I just realized...
You guys aren't leveling up because...
I just realized...
None of you are leveling up because you fainted.
Early on.
I forgot about that.
It's not me.
What?
You guys didn't know the lore?
Oh my god.
Aqua Tail?
Where'd you fuck you get the water from?
It's all grass!
Where'd you get it?
I'm surrounded by all grass.
Yes!
Yay!
Alright.
Everybody's leveling up.
Yeah!
Everyone!
Alright.
Wait.
Does he have another T-Rex?
How...
Why does he have...
Alright, right.
We're gonna need you to do a very important job.
Don't worry.
I believe in you.
Why does he have two fucking T-Rexes?
Like, is one not enough?
Alright.
Let's see.
I know I have...
What was it?
The max...
Mushroom?
Ultra Shroom.
There we go.
120...
Yeah, we'll just use the Ultra Shroom for now.
Alright.
Because why have one?
Oh, true.
True.
Double the fun.
Don't worry.
You'll be fine.
See?
Look at you!
You'll be fine!
See?
I told you you'd be fine.
Nothing to worry about.
Bye, Rice.
Your sacrifice is not in vain.
Look!
Because Dad is so healthy now.
You did it!
Pick your rice for your sacrifice.
Okay.
Storm show.
Alright.
Chuck this dinosaur.
Oh my god.
What the fuck are you eating?
A berry?
Where'd you get that berry?
Where the fuck did he eat?
It's like sneaking popcorn into the movie theater.
Who let this guy sneak in that berry?
Oh my god.
That's...
Okay.
He's not water.
He looks like water.
Because he's...
Oh wait.
He is water.
I was like...
Thank god he's not water.
Wait.
He is water.
He he he he he he he.
Can't believe it.
Who let him smuggle in another berry?
Oh shit.
Oh thank god.
Oh wait.
But he has more than...
He can do it more than once?
No!
He can do it three times!
Why is fire?
Because I used up everything else.
Alright.
It's fine.
I keep forgetting...
I'm no...
I keep forgetting dragons are resistant to fire.
I don't know why.
It's just like in my head.
I was like...
There's no way I can burn it.
Cause like...
Okay.
It's cause like you know...
You know what the meteor...
What?
And the meteor doesn't do more...
More damage?
The fucking dinosaurs got wiped out by the meteor.
I don't understand.
This doesn't make sense.
If anything should be super effective.
It should be in my fucking meteor mash.
That should kill him off!
Like...
His entire existence should be gone!
I don't understand the meteor...
Yeah!
But like...
Alright, so you know how like...
The reason why rock is so strong is flying is because of the phrase like...
Hit two...
Hit two birds with one stone?
That shit?
So like...
In that case...
I should be allowed to fucking...
Like...
Critical hit...
Like they don't even...
Like it doesn't matter what level you are...
The moment I use meteor mash...
He's just dead.
I could be a level one Mario mod...
But I fucking pull out meteor mash...
And then...
I wipe out their entire generation and existence.
That's what killed him.
And then I start the ice age.
Oh, there he is.
He's still flattened.
It doesn't matter if it's...
It's not a type.
It should be like...
The exception.
It should...
It should be the exception to the...
To the Pokemon universe.
It's almost like...
Genocide is a crime.
You know what else is a crime?
Sending a child out into...
Out into the wild...
With no supervision.
But we don't talk about that.
Splendid.
Simply splendid, Master Mario.
Your skills are as superb as ever!
Master Mario!
You're absurdly worthy of the princess's wish.
Now then...
Proceed through this door...
And continue your challenge!
Alright...
Let's see...
Don't worry...
I still have...
Wait...
Where's the DX?
Oh, thank god.
I was gonna...
I was gonna be like...
Wait...
Did I use it all up?
Kids used to play outside a lot, Doki.
Yes...
And that's why...
That's why there were a lot of kidnappings back then!
I know it's not one left!
I know I have to defeat Luigi after this!
And...
Alright, Peach's castle.
Ugh...
Alright...
It's okay, we have Dad.
Alright, Peach.
Mario!
Great job on collecting all eight Power Stars!
Now...
You only have one more challenge in front of you.
Defeating me...
And the rest of the Elite Four.
Alright...
Well, like...
It's just you.
I like...
Literally beat up your other...
Your other Elite Three.
Alright...
It's just...
Okay, she's like a normal type from what I remember.
Oh, I forgot to give the PP back.
Oh...
Okay, it's fine.
I won't need Storm Throw.
It's fine.
We don't need Storm Throw.
Oh my god...
Why is her entire Elite Four...
Like...
Good against...
Dad!
I don't understand!
Pink is powerful!
Yoshi was green.
Oh my god...
Do you think Peach is like colorblind?
If only you had...
I don't need a balanced team!
I just need one thing and one thing only.
A giant fat bomb!
Alright...
Goodbye, Birdo.
Yeah, giant bomb and heat crash.
That's all I need.
Like...
She's like pink is powerful, but she only has one pink Mario mod.
What the fuck do you mean?
Alright, there's a pink.
Okay, that's half pink.
Alright, keep crushing it.
Oh my god, it's faster?
How?
Okay...
Okay, it does nothing though.
That's good.
One point...
Yeah, it's a 1.5 pink.
There's more green than there is pink in her team.
Yeah, exactly.
If all else fails, I still have explosion.
Oh my god, she was actually the easiest out of all the ones I fought.
Does this battle remind you of our first Mario?
First what?
It's okay, I don't need my...
I don't need this.
Oh wait, I forgot.
Oh my god, it's...
It's charcoal.
It increases my fire damage.
Nevermind.
I might have needed that.
Yeah, first what?
What?
Yeah, it reminded me of our first battle.
It was still as fucking easy as it was before.
Yay!
She was actually the easiest out of entirely before.
Like...
Jesus Christ.
Excellent job.
I mean, you have no issue with a challenge like that.
You've done wonderfully, Mario.
Between stopping Bowser's schemes and collecting the Power Stars, I'm not surprised to see you at the top.
Go on.
You've got more challenges awaiting you.
Uh, Ray, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, I did it.
The weight...
The weight to the champion is now open!
Here?
Okay, I gotta heal.
Alright.
Where is...
Okay, we gotta use...
Okay, we gotta use the max one.
Is it max here?
Okay, oh, okay, that's all of them.
Alright.
We'll just make sure all of his PP is...
Is okay.
Okay.
And then...
We'll heal him up, too.
Ah!
You know what?
We'll just put 60.
Lily, uh...
Lil, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That peach boosts that stuff to my brain.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
60 is fine, actually.
Actually, no.
Alright, there we go.
That should be enough.
Alright, we fixed this PP.
Where's the...
Oh, it's up here.
The boost panel leads to the champion.
Alright, time to fight Luigi.
Oh.
I don't think I like this room.
Oh, this is like sensory overload right here.
I definitely did not like that room.
Alright, Luigi.
Fight me.
What the fuck was he wearing?
Mr. L?
I be...
I...
I be to Mario here.
I can't believe it.
No.
It's not over, bro.
I need to wait here.
Put the princess and the professor.
To come so they know it's me, Luigi.
In this disguise.
Until then, I need to hold this position.
Which means...
Luigi, are you okay?
Hark!
I hear a challenger approach.
How would it fare against...
The green lightning...
The gap champion!
The mysterious...
Mr. L.
Mario!
I...
I mean...
Ah, yes!
Mario!
The hero...
The mushroom kingdom!
It's too bad.
You're a brother.
And yet, the hero of the mushroom kingdom, Luigi.
Is nowhere to be seen.
To spectate our belt.
Oh my god.
I wonder who this guy is.
Wow!
Your mustache is awfully familiar.
Like my brother.
But it can't be.
What have you done to my brother, Mr. L?
I, Mr. L, have been here the whole time.
To serve as the champion of the cap challenge.
And will gladly accept your challenge.
Have at you!
Guys, I think it's Bowser with a mustache.
It has to be.
I've never seen him before.
Who is this man?
A green thunder strikes like lightning!
Oh my god.
It's fucking brown.
Wait.
Guys.
Is fights strong against him?
Okay.
The one time I'm asking for type advantage.
I swear to god.
This guy is fucking...
And this guy has fucking...
I'm quick.
I swear to god.
Okay.
Fire is...
Okay, so...
Oh, it's parts steel.
Okay, it's heat crash time.
It's heat crash.
Yes!
Sit on it!
Oh, there we go!
There we go!
There's Earthquake!
There it is!
Wow!
There...
Oh my god!
There it is!
There's Earthquake!
It's okay.
That has to be the only one that has Earthquake, right?
He has to be the only one that has Earthquake.
He can tank only one Earthquake.
Wait.
What did they say he was gonna stand up?
I wasn't paying attention.
Alright.
It's okay.
He can tank it.
Okay.
I swear to god, if this is another Earthquake, I...
I...
If this is...
If this is another Earthquake, I...
You know what?
It's time.
It's...
No, wait, no.
No, it's not time.
It's not time.
It's not yet.
Oh, never mind.
It is time.
He doesn't even live through that anyway.
Let's do it.
Alright.
It's okay.
Your sacrifice will not be in vain.
Alright.
I still have...
Oh my god.
I should've bought more.
No!
Oh, I should've bought more.
Oh my god.
I...
I should've bought more.
I couldn't even use it if I wanted to, guys!
That was my last revive.
Okay.
I think...
He can...
Tank this.
I'm pretty sure.
He can tank one...
He can...
Oh my god.
It's fine.
You can tank this!
Oh, you can!
Thank god!
Okay, he can.
Guys, he can.
He can tank it, guys.
Oh my god.
It doesn't even do that much.
Oh, I should've used explosion.
Oh no.
You can take this!
Okay, that's fine.
Fine.
It's fine.
He can tank it, too.
Okay.
I can't keep tanking it.
Alright.
I have to use...
Where's my golden shroom?
Oh, here it is.
I have nine of these.
I have nine of these!
It's okay.
He can...
He can keep tanking.
As long as it's not critical, we're fine.
Okay.
Okay, just use storm...
I'm not risking it.
I can't even revive if I wanted to, guys!
I used it all up!
That was my last revive!
Okay.
It's okay.
Mr. Fish.
That sounds like a water...
I have a feeling that Mr. Fish might be a water...
Water...
Okay.
I don't know.
It seems very watery.
Okay, we'll send stick bug out.
Truly not!
I swear to god.
If it's like...
If it's a fucking beta, I swear to god.
Oh my god, it's this guy.
Okay.
Let me...
Kill...
Dad real quick.
I bet it's flying!
Alright.
It's okay.
Okay.
I believe in stick bug.
I believe him a little less right now.
Oh...
I...
Yeah!
Um...
I...
I guess...
Leech life.
I guess.
Oh!
Okay.
It doesn't matter.
He's just gonna...
Oh!
It doesn't matter.
He's just gonna go crunch and then goodbye stick bug.
Goodbye!
Hey!
Yeah, I don't think stick...
Okay.
It's fine.
We have Heftly as our...
Emergency heal bot.
We're dead.
It's okay.
No!
Are you serious?!
Oh!
No!
Please!
Leave this!
Just leave this!
What the f!
Guys!
Maybe I have one
virus!
Maybe...
It has to be in here!
Okay!
No!
It's not over!
He's faster!
Okay!
It's not over yet!
It's not over yet, guys!
Okay, I think, I think it's possible.
I think it's possible.
We don't give up.
Never give up.
Oh my god.
Why did I not bring more revives?
Why was I so confident?
I hear no bell.
Lost to Mr. Fish.
Why was I so confident?
What kind of what the fuck?
Why are you so weak?
Holy shit.
Oh, no, I got too cocky.
I was like, there's no way.
There's... Oh my god.
No, the dude, I leave four all over again.
I got too cocky.
Goodbye, half-lea.
Goodbye.
Wait, wait, I can do this.
You can let... Okay, I...
Wait, no, he can.
I believe.
I will pour everything into you.
I would pour it all into you.
You got this, Anthony.
Okay.
Are you serious?
Of course you use heal.
Alright, it's five.
It's okay.
No, it's not okay.
A fucking course.
A fucking course you'd spam that!
I'm not...
A rude spam.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
It's okay.
We can spam heal too.
Also, thank you for the raid.
Thank you, thank you.
It's okay.
We also have heal.
We can also spam it.
It's a heal off.
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
I swear to fucking god.
Stop.
How much does Bruce have?
How much?
He's just trying to...
He's just trying to use up all my resources.
He's actually fucking trying to use all my resources.
Okay.
It's fine.
It benched...
Bro is just...
No!
That's all my meteor mesh!
He actually used it all up.
Oh my god.
I can't.
Cause he's flying!
He's flying!
He can't.
Oh my god.
Isn't he flying?
Oh, flying doesn't resist flying.
Okay.
Wait, I think I have one that does 200 heals.
I'm pretty sure.
Okay.
120.
I'm not risking that.
That's fine.
It's a heal off.
I still have four more.
I...
It's not!
It's not super effective!
I tried it!
It was, like, just the same.
Okay.
He's faster?
Since when?
Oh my god.
It's fighty.
It's okay.
I still have...
I still have three more shrooms.
You got this, Emily!
Oh my god.
Not ice.
Why do you have an ice move?
Oh, thank god.
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
Oh, thank god.
I thought...
Oh my god.
I don't know why I thought ice was, like, good against me.
It's fine.
You got this, Emily!
Oh!
Okay, wait, wait.
Okay.
You got this.
Just...
Just keep...
We have...
We...
There's no bell!
Oh my god.
Can you...
Okay.
He can survive another.
Just fly.
No!
Not fucking knock off!
You fucker!
Okay.
Oh my god.
There's a poo!
Okay.
I still have one more shroom.
It's okay.
What is that?
What does that do?
Dude!
That seems so strong!
Okay.
Alright.
Air slash or fly?
All or nothing, guys.
Air slash.
No.
No!
What do you...
Oh!
Fly!
Okay.
No!
I'm not...
Air slash.
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's I, Mr. L, will not acquit.
Not even at my last capture.
Okay.
We have to...
We have to heal.
I think if he hits me, I'm fucked.
There's nothing else.
Do I have another...
I have one more, right?
No.
That was my last golden shroom.
That was...
No.
Don't!
Dude!
Don't heal!
But, like, if he hits me...
If he hits me, I'm fucked!
Okay.
I have one more.
I have an ultra shroom.
Um...
That should be enough.
Okay.
Don't believe me!
Oh no!
Air slash.
Flinch!
Don't miss!
We did it!
Oh my god!
I actually...
Oh my god...
Oh my god!
I'm mysterious, Mr. L.
The view...
...to come back!
Oh my god, he did it!
I used everything I had!
Oh my god, he whipped the clutch!
We thought it was over after Dad fainted.
We thought it was over.
But we got that flinch.
I guess I should have dropped the disguise now.
Oh my god, who couldn't?
Bowser?
Don't tell I was your bro, right?
The costume makes me feel powerful and makes sure that none of the Elite Four would give me an easy fight.
Sorry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Never doubted you for a second.
Oh my god.
Even though I lost you, I'm still smiling.
I've had so much fun with you.
The Princess.
The Professor.
Bowser.
Every run that I can't be sad about any of this.
I am so glad that we were given this opportunity to play in the Kappa Challenge.
And I wouldn't change it for anything in the world, bro.
Very well said, Luigi.
Ivy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Kefliguna for the win.
Absolute cinema.
Thank you for the super chat and you're an Ivy.
Thank you.
We heard the last part of your speech.
And it almost brought me the tears.
Oh!
Oh, Princess.
I'm so sorry.
I never want to make you cry.
Now, I'm a little confused.
I see two brothers.
But, who is the champion?
It's Mario!
Professor, he gagged.
He beat me to fair and square.
I suppose that would make Mario the winner of the Kappa Challenge then.
Well done, Dokio.
And you too, Luigi.
For making it just as far.
Come.
We must record you in the Hall of Fame.
You go on ahead, bro.
I'll wait for you here for when you're done getting your wish.
Luigi, please, join us.
You can also complete a cap challenge.
You'll be recorded after Mario!
But, what about the wish?
The wish can come after... Oh, wait.
The wish can come afterwards.
Please, follow us.
Mr. Broken Bond, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, let's do this together, bro.
Wahoo!
Zekra, thank you for the 20 gifted ships!
Thank you, thank you!
Mario, what's wrong?
Okay, not gonna lie, guys.
I did not think we would have done that.
I thought... I also thought it was over.
I legitimately did not think we were gonna get flinched twice.
Fistful of herbs.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Air Slash has a 30% chance and Hefley landed two of those.
9% chance to land two flinches.
Yeah, they clutched up.
Yeah, I... I did not think we were gonna post it.
I thought it was GG.
I had to start all over.
I don't know if I heard that right, but did Mario just say Luigi is the true winner of the cap challenge?
Mario, what are you doing?
Is that what Mario say true, Luigi?
Well, Mario beat me in our last fight, but... but who got here first?
It was me!
I beat the cap challenge before Mario.
Luigi, you should have spoken up.
I was about to put Mario in the system first.
Give me a moment to change it.
Wait, but that means... All he gets... What?
Why did I say anything?
What do you mean?
What?
We lost?
I had a pure absolute cinema fight and we lost?
What is your wish, Luigi?
Luigi number one!
I love you, bro!
Wait, oh my god!
Wait, I can talk!
Love you too, bro!
What?
The one thing I said in this entire game.
The game was rigged from the start.
I never thought I would get this far.
So, I'm not going to overthink this.
And instead, wish from my heart.
My wish...
Is to go home with my breath...
Oh my god!
I gave you a wish and you wasted it?
What the fuck?
We have warp pipes, Luigi!
We...
Star, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's go, Luigi.
Never doubted you for us.
We have fly!
Warp pipes!
Taxis!
Yoshis!
I think I can do that.
Yeah, I hope you can!
Wait!
Wait, a princess!
Can I add one more thing?
What would you like, Luigi?
He...
He could have wished for world peace.
But instead, he chose to go home and do nothing about it!
I want...
A copy of Super Mario Bros.
3 for the NES!
My man!
Uh, don't you already own a copy?
Super Mario Bros.
3 over world peace.
Yes, but it's my favorite game.
And I want another copy in case we lose ours.
Anything for your wish, Champion, Luigi.
Not his job to wish for world peace.
Now, please put your caps on the computer.
Save forever more lives in the Cap Challenge Hall of Fame.
Just go to the shop.
You're not broke!
It's not like we're poor, Luigi.
We could buy that whenever.
Now it's your turn, bro.
I can't believe it.
Two months.
And Luigi...
And all I got was Luigi wishing for us to go home.
He just wants an even faster fast travel.
I can't believe it.
We are broke.
There's dead!
King of a Bomb!
There's Stickbug.
There's Dragoon.
And then Dragoon.
And then there's Ricegoon.
And our...
Shh!
Careful!
He's a hero!
There's Heflikoon!
Careful everybody!
He's a hero!
Ha ha ha ha!
Rice!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you.
Hall of Fame.
We're doing absolutely nothing.
Let's go.
You're lucky you had pretty privilege.
She didn't even instantly send me home.
What?
I still have to walk back?
I'm still walking back.
What the fuck is this?
What is my... What is your wish?
They got a lot.
Great.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Remember our first battle with Luigi where buddies survived with one each other after that self-destruct?
Good times.
Great.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
We did it.
But we did have one extra...
We did have some after... Was it post-game things I want to do?
So it's not over yet, guys.
It's not over yet.
We have... I think one or two post-credits things I want to do before we...
We end it here.
Yeah.
Just one or two.
Depending on how I feel after one.
I guess we do have a second stream tonight.
And it's Rune Factory.
And I think... And um... I want to have like too little energy for that.
By the way... Rune Factory... I've never played Rune Factory before too.
But yeah.
Thank you for Alpharad... For... And his team... For making such a great ROM hack.
It was really fun.
I had a great time.
But yeah.
I heard it's like a farming RPG.
So there's like... You can farm.
And you also have... And there's also RPG elements.
And like... I saw people in chat were saying that...
Um... The newest game of Rune Factory...
Uh... Streamlined a lot of things.
So it's easier for newcomers to try it out.
Which is me.
I'm new.
Yeah.
Well it's not just like... It's like...
So it's like... You know.
Like what you see in JRPGs.
But they added like farming in it too.
From what I've read.
You should play Factorio.
I don't know if I tried Factorio before.
I know there was like a... A factory like...
Game.
Where you're on a planet.
And I'd like... Play like 5-10 minutes of it.
And I was like... I was so overwhelmed.
That I just refunded the game.
I don't know if that's... Oh it's a satisfactory.
Maybe it's... It's where you're like... On a plant...
No it's not Planet Crafter.
Planet Crafter was very easy.
I enjoyed Planet Crafter.
But there was... I think it was Satisfactory.
I tried to do a Satisfactory.
And then I played like 10 minutes of it.
And then it was like... You got...
There's like so many things.
So many items.
And builds.
And like instructions.
And then I looked at the menu.
Like the crafting menu.
For like... I think like...
5 minutes.
And then I closed the game.
And refunded it.
Because I knew like...
I was not...
I was not learning anything.
I...
This brain was not learning jack shit.
I swear to god.
If like...
If I...
I can't believe I just walked home after like...
Luigi told Peach that he...
His fucking special wish that took 2 months to get...
Was to be TP'd back home.
I...
Alright.
Let's do the post content.
Look at that.
We're back home.
Oh.
That was one heck of a battle, eh bro?
You really wallowed me.
Even my special disguise.
Yeah.
I want to give you something.
Thanks for being a wonderful brother.
And congratulations for defeating me.
A piranha happy.
After you beat me.
I went ahead and let my party rest at the Diamond City Daycare.
Little did I know.
Good old buddy had left behind an egg.
I didn't even know piranha happy could do that.
Oh my god.
What?
You're just...
Did you ask him if he...
Did you ask the mom if like...
She was okay that you literally gave away her child?
Also, the professor was here earlier.
He told me that there's still plenty left to do in the Kappa Challenge.
And to keep filling up our title decks.
I think I'll be taking a break though.
And staying at home for a while.
Everyone ever better though.
Just give me a call at the Mushroom Hill.
And me and my team will take you on anytime.
He just like...
Threw away her child.
Just like that.
She like gave birth and was like...
Goodbye Sonic!
Wow!
We gotta get Sonic!
Alright.
Dark Blade!
Thank you for the Super Chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Can I please have Sonic named after me?
Please, please, please!
I've been wanting to ask since the beginning of your playthrough.
Alright, jump the block.
Alright, how desperate are you, Dark Blade?
It's Sonic the Hedgehog.
No, no, no.
Medi and John gave me permission.
Oh my god!
It's the hills!
Sonic's the name, spins my game.
Oh my god.
You're too slow!
Oh my god, I am too slow.
Our Dark Blade keep begging until we get to Sonic.
And then I'll think about it.
We just didn't press charges!
Medi, thank you for the Super Chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh!
It makes a sound effect when you go past it, too!
That's cute.
I like that.
Ba-dum-ba-dum-bum-bum.
Oh, yeah!
This is happening!
Alright.
It's time.
Sonic the name, spins my game.
Oh my god!
Excuse me, he's level 70?
Oh, fuck!
I'm scared if I sit on him, he'll actually just die.
Okay, but what if I just...
Wait, I can't capture him right off the bat?
Wait, I cannot be used right now.
Oh.
Wait, it won't let me use it right now.
Oh my god, he's so strong.
Guys, I remembered that I have no heals.
Oh my god, I almost won!
Okay, thank god he didn't just die.
He didn't just die!
I was like, I'm scared.
I think he could...
I think, like, I legitimately could actually kill him if I just sat on him.
I...
I was so scared.
Wait, I still can't catch him?
What if I just explode?
Oh my god.
I don't think he's living.
Oh.
I did...
Alright, Rice.
This is your time to shine.
You're too slow.
This is it.
Oh.
This is...
This is it.
It's time.
We will surely live long enough.
I can't capture him.
I tried.
It said no.
He will pressure you.
Alright.
Nice capture.
I tried.
I swear to god.
Oh, when I lowered him to 1 HP...
I have to lower him to 1...
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, wait.
That's not fine.
Wait.
He's gonna die.
I petitioned the name to be signed.
I mean, thank you for the super...
Guys.
I think he might die.
The one time...
I was like...
You got...
You can't support me now, Rice.
And then...
We got...
Rice still finds a way.
It's not my fault.
Alright.
It's okay.
He's still...
This is the more faking you demand in Darkplate.
Thank you.
Oh, wait!
Wait, I can do this?
Oh, it's like...
Okay, that wasn't supposed to happen... Alright, the game was like, wait a minute... Never punish...
Yeah.
The game was like, okay, Doki.
You were not supposed to... You were not supposed to kill Sonic.
I didn't know!
You fucking... Alright, rest.
Oh, fuck!
No, I forgot!
You can still have perished!
You still have perished!
I forgot when you die, you still... Oh, my God!
I'm so stupid!
I... Okay.
Okay.
It's fine.
The perished... It's fine.
As long as you don't die, it's like... Doki.
Come on.
I forgot.
It's okay.
Rice lived.
Rice lived, guys.
The ability did trigger.
Darkplate.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, shit.
Meep and Darkplate are gonna fight for the role of Sonic.
Oh, my God!
Okay.
Just perished again.
For...
I...
Okay.
Clearly, you can tank this, right?
Cause I need to heal up.
I need to heal up that real quick.
I'm pretty sure...
Yeah.
I still have one more Ultras room.
I can't.
Apparently, Sonic has to be one HP.
Oh, my God.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha!
What do you need Sonic?
Darkwing instead of Darkplate.
Manny, thank you, the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
This is awkward.
Great.
Alright.
I think Dad can survive this.
I think he can survive this.
Guys, I don't...
Guys, I don't think he survived this, guys.
I...
It's okay.
I have Earthquake.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God!
The power...
Okay, whoops.
Never mind.
What type is he?
A very scary kind.
Oh...
Okay, first impression.
This is it.
Oh, this is not it.
Guys.
I think...
I think Sonic might beat me up, guys.
I think Sonic might beat me up.
Bryce!
You just need to survive!
Oh, my God.
Sonic's gonna take my lunch money.
I still can't throw it.
It has to be one HP, guys.
I still...
Oh, my God.
Please!
I lost!
Oh, my God.
He took my lunch money.
I'm back home.
It's like a fucking fever dream.
Oh, my God.
If only we had some revives.
Is he just, like, waiting for me over there?
He's too fast.
He really is too fast.
Okay.
Do I actually...
Okay, yeah.
He's waiting for me.
Okay.
We gotta buy some heals.
Alright.
I'm, like...
I'm desperate for heals.
Okay.
There should be, like...
I might be able to buy one-ups right here.
Okay.
Not here.
No.
I got him.
Okay.
Half.
We'll buy...
10.
We don't need that many.
We'll buy...
Let's buy...
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's just feed Dad.
I...
I got...
I got this.
I believe.
You.
Alright.
Before we fight Sonic...
Wait.
Where's home?
Where do I live?
Where the fuck do I live?
Here?
Okay.
I gotta use the bathroom.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'm back.
Uh...
Whoa.
Alan, Mehdi, fight!
Lil!
Zekra, Nyur!
Plus!
Bryce!
Johnny!
Mike!
Nexi!
Floor!
Meep!
Aphelion!
Champions!
Thank you!
Alright.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to beat up Sonic!
Can't believe he took my lunch money!
Can't believe it!
He fucking took my lunch money and then left me to die!
Alright.
Now I don't need to save.
Not so Deadpool!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Get mugged, nerd!
I have to go all the way back, too.
Wait, I should have...
Can you see?
Oh, I can!
Okay.
That's good.
The guy could use the Yoshi.
I was gonna say, that's gonna take me fucking forever.
Run over here.
I like how Sari was like, wait...
Okay, wait a minute.
You were not supposed to kill me.
I like broke this...
He's like, wait.
That is not canon.
Alright.
I'm back again!
This time!
I actually have heals!
Hold on.
That's illegal.
That's right.
I know what to do now.
He crashed!
There's no way he can one-shot me when...
Okay.
I...
Slow it!
I was gonna be like...
Wait.
Can he actually one-shot me?
Alright.
Oh, yeah?
Okay.
And then, all I have to do...
You'll be fine.
You'll be okay.
I know his move is like 20 seconds long.
You can tank this.
See?
I told you!
You can...
I've always believed in you, son!
I've always believed in you!
Look!
You can come out of the attic!
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Maybe you won't survive that.
Alright.
Don't worry.
You've done...
You've done your job.
Don't worry.
You did what you were supposed to do.
Alright.
Now.
Heat crash.
Oh, thank God.
I was like...
Oh, that is going down awfully fast.
I don't like how fast that's going.
Alright.
But how many times is he gonna use Acrobat?
Surely not all the time.
Surely it'll be fine.
Oh, nice.
Okay, we're fine.
See?
I told you!
Oh, that's still a lot.
That's...
Alright.
Oh, can he stop?
Yes, he can.
Yes, he can!
Okay.
Yes, he can.
He can't stop that.
It's...
It's okay.
We have...
Alright.
He's...
It's okay.
I have Earthquake.
Okay, there we go.
Alright, Dragoon.
Use Earthquake!
That'll make him one HP.
Alright.
Now's your chance.
This is it!
Some bear...
Oh, wait.
That was not the right one.
Okay.
Alright, I used the wrong cap.
Whoops.
Surely...
I was like...
This is it!
Oh, wait.
That was...
That was the wrong cap.
Alright, Rice.
Just live for like...
One Mexican Sonic.
No!
Yes!
Oh, my God!
Mexican...
No!
What's...
Hey, you could love Latinos too!
Oh, my God!
Thank God!
Now...
Now we use the right one!
We almost had Mexican Sonic!
Oh, no!
Oh, this is not good!
This is...
This is a little not good!
What even...
What even is the sombrero?
I need it.
I'm actually...
Okay.
Oh!
Taking many turns!
Wait!
We used a lot of turns!
Wait, actually...
Actually, it might work.
It might work out.
What is...
It's a hat, Toki.
Okay, that's a lot...
We used a lot of turns...
Okay, never mind.
Clearly...
It needs to be like 40 turns.
Oh!
Instructions were definitely unclear.
It was...
I just thought that was enough turns.
Okay.
That's five.
Yes.
It's okay.
I have...
Oh, it's only 10?
Okay, we definitely used more than 10.
Okay.
Alright.
We...
I'm pretty sure we used more than 10.
I'm pretty sure.
Where's my...
What up?
Oh, there it is.
I was like, where the fuck did I put this?
Okay, I have rezzed.
The only issue...
Is that...
Um...
Wait, I have a ma...
Where did I have a master cap?
Oh my god.
Wait.
I have one?
When did I got one?
You guys are fucking...
Oh my god.
You guys are fucking liars.
It's fucking lying.
Why do I have two helmet cap?
Guys.
Do we risk it with...
Mexican Sonic?
Alright.
Let's see.
This is my last chance.
Oh my god.
You fuckers.
Why did you...
He's mugging me again.
He took my lunch money again.
Oh my god.
He took all my money.
He he he he.
He he he.
I told you not...
You fuckers.
My money.
He he he he.
Adios amigas.
I request Sonic.
Not Sonic but...
Dark Blade.
Sonic.
No we're fine.
Okay, guys.
I know how to...
Guys.
Do you guys want to know how to efficiently level up?
Watch this.
Alright, Ryze, this is your time to shine.
This is how... Okay, if you guys want me to... Okay, I'll level up, like, one time against Sonic.
And this is how we're gonna do it.
This is... Ryze, this is your time to shine.
I just hit you.
Ryze, this is it.
This is your purpose.
We're gonna be stuck on a time loop, guys.
We're gonna be stuck in a loop.
In a fucking time loop.
Until, until dad is, like, level... Okay, not until level 100.
No, I don't think I can do that for that long.
We're gonna be in a time loop.
It's Groundhog Day.
Okay.
Aw, yeah!
You're too slow!
Alright, here we go.
Alright, Ryze.
Do what you're...
Do what you're known for.
Oh, thank God, I was gonna say.
Alright, nice.
Okay, now...
Now we can both die.
I don't think you're gonna be able to live long enough to do that, Ryze.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
It's okay.
It's okay, I can tank three...
I can tank three moves.
Toki, wait!
No, he does.
You know how I know this?
Because we tried it.
You know, that's...
I know this because we...
We killed him already and it, like, reset...
The world resetted stuff because it wasn't canon.
Next thing, thank you to the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Do you really want Ryze to do what he's known for?
Honestly.
Wait, there's no way.
Yeah, see, look.
Alright.
Yeah, you think you won this, Sonic?
You really think you won this?
Watch this.
Oh, wait.
Dad died.
Wait, he was...
Wait, wait!
No, he was supposed to get the XP!
I forgot!
He was supposed to get the XP!
Alright, there we go.
See?
It's...
We're looping.
We're in a time loop.
We're in a time loop again!
Okay, I don't think you're gonna be able to live that long.
Mission failed successfully.
That's right!
I got you now, Sonic!
I got you now!
No, it's fine.
You can't take my lunch money no more, Sonic!
That's fucking right!
That's right!
My lunch money will stay with me!
He stopped killing rice when he's been through it now.
Alright.
Use Earthquake.
He's gonna die anyway.
I can't catch him.
He has to be 1 HP.
Alright.
Thank you for your sacrifice.
Now he gets XP.
And now Sonic is going to get one shot!
Bye!
It's okay!
We're looping!
Back to the time loop we go!
Nice!
Okay, now we don't have to level up anymore.
Yay!
Whoa!
What happened?
Yeah!
Okay, now...
We use Strength Sap.
Bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum.
Bum bum!
Holy shit!
Okay.
It's fine.
Now everything should be good.
Everything will be okay now.
Alright.
Okay, now...
I...
Okay.
I didn't expect to go that far.
Yeah, but now Sonic's gonna die.
Sonic's gonna die now.
Now we loop him.
Now we just loop him.
Guys, I think he's gonna die.
Wait, does...
Do you think the loop works?
For, like, Sombrero?
It doesn't matter, guys!
It just resets him anyway!
It's okay.
We're just XP farming.
Yeah, it's probably just for the one battle.
Alright.
Yeah, Bryce doesn't need XP, guys.
Guys.
It's okay.
Rice does not need the XP.
Goodbye.
It was nice seeing you, Transformer.
Wow.
It is my life.
Oh shit!
Last Resort!
Nice!
An actual good move!
Wait, actually, no.
Nevermind.
It's a terrible move.
I thought it was something else.
Back to the time loop!
No, it's bad.
Alright, okay.
Now we try.
Alright.
I think I got this.
My sacrifice.
Alright.
Stick bug.
Die for our sins.
We got this.
It's okay.
Everything will be fine.
No, we can't use the sap yet.
Because if we use it...
Before...
Okay, use next capture.
Okay.
Now...
All we need to do...
Is put dad in here.
And then...
We crush him.
It's fine.
It's...
Okay.
Everything is okay.
Okay, and now... Okay, and now, after that,
after that, all we need to do is... Give me a sec, I'm thinking.
Alright, you can tank this.
I know you can.
I know you can, son.
I know you can take this.
Okay, and then we... Earthquake.
Okay, I don't know if you can tank that, though.
I don't...
No, my Earthquake!
Okay.
That's fine.
I have an idea.
Alright, this is it.
Watch this.
This is fine.
Oh!
Okay, wait.
Wait.
I know what to do.
Guys, watch this.
Okay.
I didn't think you'd die.
But don't worry.
Don't... Don't worry.
Everything will be fine.
I'm watching.
It's okay.
You can survive this.
Okay.
That's fine.
That's... That's more than fine.
That's... That... You... You've done what you have to do.
You've done what you have to do.
That's fine.
But now.
Now.
Watch this.
He lives through this.
I know it.
Oh my god.
Come on.
Give me that one.
No, are you serious?
Weaker than Heat Crush.
How?
How is it?
It's weaker.
My money.
Oh my god.
I didn't know it's weaker.
Okay, guys.
I need to spend my money or he's gonna keep taking my money.
I don't want him to keep taking my money, guys.
I can't take my money if I'm broke.
No, it's okay.
Guys.
We can't... If we save scum, we'll never learn.
We'll never learn if we save scum, guys.
We'll never learn.
We got this.
Guys.
I don't need a level up.
I'm at the perfect level.
We're at 69.
I can't ruin this.
We can't ruin the perfect number.
All right.
This is it.
I figured it out.
Okay.
I know what to do.
All right.
Okay.
All we have to do is...
We heat crush.
We heat crush first.
And then I'll... And then we'll see what happens after that.
Let's see.
It's fine.
I know my mistakes.
I know what to do, guys.
It's fine.
I now know the explosion does less damage than heat crush.
I can't believe it.
How does it do less damage than...
Okay.
All right.
That's right, Sonic.
That's right.
Okay.
Here we go.
Ba-dum.
All right.
This is fine.
I know who can tank this.
Okay.
All right.
You can tank two hits.
I know you can.
You got this.
I'm letting you out of the attic.
Take two hits for dad.
That's all you need to do.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
I don't ask for much.
I just need you to take two hits.
So he can live and heat crush.
All right.
This is it.
Okay.
Good.
You've done your job.
That's all you had to do.
You did your job.
Oh, yeah.
And now... I heat crush.
I heat crash.
Let's go.
Okay.
I know like as long as it's not a critical hit, we live this.
That should be it.
That's all we need.
That should be one HP.
What?
Since when was it not one hit?
It was one hit before.
I swear to God.
Oh, come on Dragoon.
Oh, thank God.
How did he get stronger?
It was one hit before.
Oh, was it a critical hit?
I must have had a critical hit.
I'm not throwing sombrero.
Guys, we're not throwing the sombrero.
We're not throwing it.
Oh, my God.
He's so strong.
I have three balls.
Okay.
It's okay.
Come on.
Shirley will have the critical chance.
Shirley will be lucky.
Shirley!
No, we still have hope.
I have two more shots.
Come on.
Two more shots.
It's not even close.
I have one more.
I have one more shot.
Rice, this is it.
Rice.
This is it, Rice.
This is it.
We end...
We...
This is it.
Sombrero time.
Oh!
Oh my!
Mexican Sonic is real!
It works.
I know...
We'll never doubt...
Mexican Sonic!
I can't believe it works!
We literally just need it.
I can't believe it!
I can't believe it's the time!
Oh my God!
We got Sonic.
A blue hedgehog.
And the fastest thing alive.
A friend to all.
And it backed into a corner.
He'll unleash an ultimate power.
With a seven chaos emerald.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Lolly, thank you.
I can't believe we got Mexican Sonic.
I have our last Mario Kart.
I was like, fine, I'll throw this on Braille.
We're gonna die anyway.
I'll fucking do it.
Darkblade, I really want to name this.
I really want to, but I also really, really want to name...
Darkblade, you, you understand though, right?
Oh, there's no heart?
Usually there's a heart for the symbol.
Oh, there's no heart for the symbol.
I just love Latinas.
I highly...
I gave my blessing.
Darkblade, thank you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Just for you.
B for... Okay.
No, actually, I was gonna say it'll be...
It might be bad.
I mean, like, I'll give, like, an abbreviation, but I realize that might be bad.
Alright.
Latina.
No, I just realized.
Okay.
Wait.
I'm sorry, Darkblade.
And, uh, we all know this is Darkblade Sonic, but also...
It's like... It's like... It's like bracket, Darkblade.
Bracket.
Metal Sonic implies the possibility of a female Sonic.
But that's true.
We all... I'll be like, bracket, bracket, Darkblade.
Wait.
Love Latina shit.
D-B.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Latina's... Darkblade.
Alright.
Here we go.
We have Mexican Sonic.
Let's go.
Sad... Excellent.
Oh, it looks like a thumbs up!
Wait, it does!
Wait, you're right!
It looks like a thumbs up!
Latina's... Thumbs up!
The quest... Yay!
Get in my cap!
Dude, thumbs up!
Perfect.
Oh my god, the survivor!
Yeah, it looks...
Okay, wait.
We could do like... What if I just release him?
Alright.
Thank you for your service, Rice.
Wait.
Thank you for your service.
Wait, does it look like... Okay.
I'm curious.
I'm here.
Okay.
Do I do like... D...
Wait.
What's this look more like?
D...
Okay.
Does this look more... Which one looks more like a thumbs up?
Capital D?
Or like...
Which looks more like a thumbs up, guys?
What?
Oh, capital...
Capital D.
Okay.
We'll do that.
Alright.
Let's fix this.
Let's fix this real quick.
Latina's...
I... We... We like...
Fucking renamed him so many times.
Okay.
Now it looks like a thumbs...
Now it properly looks like a thumbs up.
There we go.
It does.
Okay.
There we go.
Now it... Now it definitely...
Perfect.
It's beautiful.
I can't believe we did it, guys.
We fucking did it.
Alright.
Let's head home.
Wait.
I can't leave?
Oh my god.
He won't let me leave.
It's like...
Alright.
Let's see real quick.
I have to do like the walk of shame all the way back.
Zeon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Not so Deadpool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We don't have enough space.
Zeon, unfortunately.
We only...
We have to have dot dot dot dot.
It only makes perfect sense.
But we did it.
We finally finished...
Super Mario mod.
What a journey that we had today.
What a fucking journey.
I can't believe...
The sombrero worked.
I...
I can't believe it.
It actually worked.
I did not expect the sombrero to be...
I...
I expected to die.
I really did expect it to die.
There.
But wow.
What a fucking journey.
Today.
Oh.
We finished another game.
That was fun though.
It was fun...
Playing...
A Pokemon game.
Technically a Pokemon game again.
After what?
12...
12 years?
Um...
Just revisiting like the Pokemon formula.
It's been very...
So long.
But it was nice to try Super Mario mod.
I huge shout again to Alpha Rad for...
Um...
And his team for doing...
Making this game.
I had incredibly fun.
And I've had a whole...
Had a lot of fun...
Uh...
Having guys a lot...
Part of the journey.
And...
Uh...
And you know...
Being on my team and everything.
And watching me name everybody.
Um...
It was a great time.
I do have another stream...
Later today.
So...
It's not the last you'll seem for me today.
Uh...
So...
And like...
I think like...
What?
In three more hours.
So I'm gonna rest a little bit...
Before my next stream in three hours.
Uh...
But thank you all for joining.
Thank you all for coming here to watch...
The end of the stream...
To watch the end of the series.
Um...
I noticed I could fight the devs.
But like I feel like...
I feel like it's gonna take a while.
So...
I feel like our devs are, like, gonna be a lot harder, so I'm like, I'm not gonna... I'm not gonna try it.
But thank you all for watching.
We had a lot of fun watching.
We had a lot of fun with this series.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up with me, head to bed or stay up for a little longer for my RuneFactor stream.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, everyone.
Bye!